Robin was on vacation and I saw that
these characters that she hangs around
where they got her on for a virtual
wine-tasting we've got miss even keel
Robin Quivers the videos up to 35 whole
views on YouTube poor Robin sitting
there for basically a private
conversation by the way you know Robin
was on this show and she starts telling
the story of when she bought eight
hundred dollar bottle of wine on my dime
and boy oh boy
you never can admit you might have been
wrong I was listening to this wait a
minute I said I was wrong no did you
listen to this Gary I did you say that
somehow telepathically Howard was
supposed to know how much the wine was
no I didn't say it was telepathic I was
trying to indicate to him by sending the
guy over to him that what was I supposed
to scream I was supposed to scream at
the table yeah you don't want another
bottle of this wine yes yeah that's
exactly what you should have done no
we're good we're good
no I should yell that listen to this do
you have wine from a French winery that
I have been to and he says yes and so I
ordered one bottle of wine and I thought
well that's a pricey bottle of one but
it's only one so there were six people
at the table so one bottle just went
just like that wasn't gonna hand this
male comes over after he sees the bottle
empty door after it emptied he said
would you like another to me and I said
no you better go check with him and I
was doing that to try to give Howard the
indication that he had a look him
spending that kind of money if you
didn't want to so anyway two sips of
wine these three sheets to the wind
there was another one and then he got
the bill and he almost threw up
no I threw up and never saw word to me
until we got back on the air Monday
morning I get the bill I went like this
like like my breath yeah I I went like
this I did Gary saw it I don't even look
at the price when I take you out I pay I
knew I was in trouble before I got the
bill the waiter presented everyone with
envelopes with the labels from the wine
bottles and I went this must be some
[ __ ] crazy bottle of wine Lord so at
the end of that dinner the bill came and
I just saw the first digit on the bill
and I remember thinking there's six of
us so this is like the world's most
expensive restaurant if it's $250 a head
right that would be like $1,800 and I
saw the first digit was a four so
observant Baba Booey